ننوه مره اخرى لهذه العواجل بحسب ابو
عبيده اذا العدو تعمد يقول بالامس اعدام
ثلاثه من جنوده واثر قتلهم على تحريرهم
وهو سلوك اجرامي مارسه ولا يزال بحق اسرى
اذا الناطق باسم كتاب القسام يقول دائما
العدو لا يزال يقامر كما قلنا بحياه جنوده
الاسرى لدى المقاومه وغير ابه
بمشاعر عائلاتهم مره اخرى ما الذي تقراه
اذا في هذا التصريح عندما يقول ابو عبيده
ان العدو يتعمد اعدام جنوده من الاسرى اذا
واثر قتلهم على تحريرهم وهو سلوك اجرام
اجرامي كما يقول ابو عبيده مارسه ولا يزال
بحق
الاسرع طيب في في هذه القضيه يعني عندما
يتكلم نتنياهو وتتكلم القيادات العسكريه
والامنيه بان هناك انفاق في غزه وهذه
الانفاق تستخدم من قبل المقاتلين سواء
لسرايا القدس او لبقيه المقاتلين في
الفصائل الاخرى بما فيهم كتائب عز الدين
القسام والاسرى يتواجدون في بعض هذه
المناطق يعني حسب اللقاءات التي اجريت مع
بعض الاسرى الذين تم اطلاق سراحهم بانهم
يتواجدون في بعض الانفاق طيب عندما تقوم
هذه الحكومه ويقوم الجيش بعمليه
وضع بوضع لاغم بوضع انابيب لغرض اغمر هذه
الانفاق بالماء ماذا يعطي دليل هذا هذا
يعطي دليل واضح على انه لا يابه بارواح
بارواح الاسرى الموجودين لدى حماس كانوا
في الانفاق والا لو كان حريص على هذا
الامر لما قام بالاقدام على مثل هذه
العمليه يضاف الى ذلك هو عندما يقول باننا
نستطيع الوصول نعم استطعتم الوصول الى احد
الجنود قبل ايام اللي هو ساعر باروخ ولكن
ادى الى مقتله هذه العمليه الثانيه ايضا
وصلتم الى اماكن تتواجد فيه الاسرى ولكن
ايضا قتلوا اذا المقاربه الامنيه لغرض
اطلاق سراح الاسرى لن تكون مجديه مهما
طالت الحرب والدليل على هذا بان الترتيبات
الموجوده لدى فصائل القسام و وبقيه
الفصائل الاخرى فيها ترتيبات دفاعيه محكمه
في بالنسبه في قضيه الاسرى لان لا يمكن ان
تتحمل كتائب عز الدين القسام وغزه هذا
القصف التدميري الكبير وهذه الخسائر ثم
يقومون باعطائكم هذه الاسرى بدون اي مقابل
هذه القضيه ما ممكن ان يكون التفكير فيها
يعني ام